the magic moment we're looking live
punctuatawny they're waiting to find out
if he sees his shadow kelly help me out
put your hand on the king yeah
there he is the star himself we're
waiting to see is there more six more
weeks of winter no just bite him in the
nose
just bite him phil all right come on we
got our prediction oh hey
are you ready
oh they got a scroll they have to read
it oh my goodness yeah because it wasn't
pre-printed ahead of time or anything oh
jeez okay here it is
today yeah 2
2
22. exactly
welcome to punxsutawney to celebrate
groundhog day good night the
136th annual trek of the punxsutawney
groundhog approval for this 136
the
times
of all prognosticators until murray was
gently lifted from his borough yes he
was 7 25 a.m back to bed held high to
see
he might be his faithful followers had
returned with glee
placing phil on top of the stump
wearing groundhog ease
he directed the president
jeff lundy
to his prediction scroll that reads yeah
yeah right
winter
has been bleak
dark
and brief of hope
yet winter is just another step in the
cycle of life he doesn't have a producer
in his area
like we do of the true believers from
around the world okay mr shakespeare
tolstoy with this script here
he's just hanging out oh my god i lost
my place oh my goodness dude i bask in
the warmth of your hearts
i couldn't imagine
a better fate
with my shadow i have calves okay than a
long lustrous six more weeks of winter
six more weeks of winter no real
surprise there it's cold here phil saw
his shadow makes you want to go back to
your stump